let's do a little gay stuff haven't done
anything gay in a couple of weeks at
least on the show
Jane Lynch who's I'd say she might be
America's top lesbian right now she's
right Ellen and her really fighting for
the top spot in the lesbian marathon I
guess she announced that she's getting
divorced from her partner of three years
and I thought this was interesting
because I feel like every gay person
feels that they have to be the perfect
gay person now in the perfect gay couple
and does a high profile gay person
getting divorced actually hurt the
movement for equality and we got DOMA
and prop 8 that are gonna be decided
this month by the Supreme Court and all
that stuff Sean as a noted homosexual
yeah I think that that we should accept
gay marriage and gay divorce because I I
know I'm not getting married to my
partner for the community I'm getting
married to my partner because I love him
and I want to marry him and I don't
think that I should be have to be held
up to a certain standard just for
political reasons right you know I don't
think we should be a couple that's like
we're having a terrible time where we're
going to stay together just because he's
gonna say so yeah it just doesn't yes
you actually are getting married no
Julia no nothing on your humble but yeah
so you feel no X did you feel any extra
pressure to get married because I am
feeling that a little bit with the gay
community too that people that are in
relationships are feeling like they have
to make a political statement suddenly
and say that they're gonna get married
no III don't I felt that's just we're
life we're living her life like we're
married already we are drinking her
Pinot Grigio and and watching our DVR
and going to sleep and paying $50 a
month for a gym membership we never go
to a nice terrible I know we're
basically married so I think just having
our family there to celebrate it is
perfect the right dad is a redneck but
he loves chip and he he's so excited to
go to the wedding and I and I'm actually
gonna be my only sibling that's gonna be
married
out of three other straight siblings so
I am forging ahead for the Hollenbach
name yeah you're really changing the
people in rural Pennsylvania just go to
my Kickstarter for my adoption Jed what
do you think should gay people as you a
higher standard for that should be so
ridiculous I'm stupid that anybody would
ever even if you're the type of [ __ ]
that's gonna be like those gay people
got divorced seeing gays can't get
married then like go kill yourself end
it yourself I think you're a nicer
person I'm like no do please do that was
actually the best It Gets Better
campaign that the divorce rate for
straight people is pretty high so if
people are gonna be people they're not
always gonna get along things aren't
always gonna work out and it'd be nicer
if more people stay together and learn
to work out their problems with their
partners rather than being like well we
had a fight or or I want to go bang this
person so you know let's get divorced be
nicer straight people and you know gay
and lesbians all decided to work on
their relationships and stay together
but if you don't you should be able to
get out without worrying like it's gonna
be politicized or that now you're gonna
take away the ability for other people
to celebrate their love just because
like you married a douche the way a
single straight people end up doing to
marry douches all the time yeah isn't
that the crazy part that you know gay
people feel this pressure to get married
then this feel this pressure to not get
divorce and it becomes this sort of
never-ending cycle when we just want if
it just goes to show if you just give
people equality they'll act just like
everyone else right and they're just
like us
do you fear at all that like with all
the equality one day when it's just all
everything's even and a kid can come out
no one will give a [ __ ] and a basketball
player can come out and it won't matter
do you think that the gays will actually
lose something that there is something
special about being different that's why
so much creativity comes out of the gays
but the leather bars will all disappear
yeah I mean no really though do you
think that that's legit I think that the
community will lose like
something special yeah I feel like
there's a there is sort of an old gay vs
new gay one of one of your jokes is
there our guy old guys saying that I had
to climb a mountain does penis you know
yeah I don't know if I could say it I
don't know if he can say you could say I
can say jerry-san
dick dick dick dick dick okay got it
back in our day we had to suck dick yeah
we had to climb up hill to suck dick
it's an old joke right but I feel like
there's still there's still a subset of
people that are saying I remember when
New York was fun and being gay was fun I
think being gay is just as fun now as it
ever was still doing the same things
it's not I I don't see what the big
difference as people are different to
some people okay you're gonna wanna know
live in New York City and party and you
know suck different dick
and then there's gonna be other gay
people that are just like whoa I want to
be in a monogamous relationship and I
just want that one exactly just one dick
vagina as it may be so brilliant that's
like saying penis vagina what's the what
a lesbians refer to the vaginas do they
say vagina to each other see the flower
yeah but these are that concept though
about the this sort of longing for the
old days that's what that Woody Allen
movie Midnight in Paris was about that
we always think that something before us
powerful it wasn't and it just wasn't
right like do you I mean do you think
back on something some other time and
think it was probably better but there
was a lot of bad [ __ ] going on - I'm
from New York
I romanticize in New York and old New
York and I think about walking through
the city streets and how beautiful it
was and I don't think about how half the
time I was like I can't get from cab I
don't think about all the misery that I
romanticized past relationships and
think about the great things about them
when I'm in a current one that's not
necessarily as romantic or as special as
that one so we all romanticized the past
we like to do that so you don't have to
confront our current situation really it
was so much better when XYZ yeah
when there were subway murders I miss
that
people always bring up the bad stuff
they were serial murders out in New York
City and suddenly our conditioning in
the subways do we still do we have
orchid no there's air conditioning now
but there was a time when there wasn't
which i think is crazy just I don't miss
them